Basketball Hall of Famer joining is here
on the Rich Eisen show rec you were a
teaching tool in my house recently
unbeknownst to you I'm sure well well
that's great that I hopefully you gave
the proper technique I didn't show them
how to do it I used your your footage to
show them how it's done I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that but if if you wouldn't
mind coming down to the Los Angeles area
and sure you know coming by the house
maybe wow that would be great
how old are they there are ten and eight
yeah well you gotta use a smaller ball
because you know you got to have your
hands over the top of the ball a little
bit the problem is when kids start doing
the younger they get their hands on
their ball and they develop a technique
that well it's nice to do it because you
get a feel for it but it's not good
technique that you want to use if you're
actually going to get really proficient
at it later in life see that's why I
need you Rick you know I would not I
would not cheap inexpensive let's say
that okay you're in it say I was I was
inexpensive when I play but I'm looking
at what these guys are getting good
they forgot three zeros on my contract
thanks rich lowest paid guy is the NBA
this year counting the money they get
from NBA properties will probably make
twice as much as I made in the best year
I ever had the guy that never plays
mm-hmm unbelievable times have
definitely changed Rick Perry I'm sure
for them I'm sure so let's get into the
finals right now Rick what is the what
is the mood around the team best you can
tell around the Warriors right now down
to one well I've been around I've been
round the players I'll be at the game
tonight I'm sure they're all very
disappointed that they're like a MASH
unit I mean they have so many injuries
and so many problems going for them but
that's part of what Sports is about it's
unfortunate to come down and play your
whole season and come down to a chance
to play for another championship and not
be at full strength so Toronto did what
they had to do if I were the Warriors
though I'd be happy about what happened
their last game you know why cuz they're
gonna lose a game I don't think that
Toronto can shoot the ball as well as
they shot the ball in that last game in
any of the remaining games in this
series and they shot out of their mind
and they did it for the pleated team so
if they don't shoot that way
and clay comes back and Katy comes back
in the Warriors play any kind of
reasonable basketball I don't think that
Toronto can shoot that well to beat them
so do they need Durant to pull this off
Rick not necessarily it all depends upon
if clay is back and really can play at a
high level I mean your boogie didn't
have a good game there she's a great
game at number two I think what really
hurts a lot is the Kevin Looney has been
places he was playing so well for them
doing so many good things and and that
hurts so other guys are gonna have to
step up a little bit but they have to
have every cent this rich about the
Warriors when you play them you have to
pray the two of their three main guys
are having bad shooting games of course
that's with you know what with the rant
and with with clay and with Steph and if
that happens you know you have a really
good chance of beating up only one guys
off you're still gonna have to play
really well to beat them and so now that
if KD isn't playing they have to have
both of those guys playing exceptionally
well for them to be able to win the game
and of course drayman's got to play at
the level that he's been playing at he
wasn't as good in the last game as he'd
been prior games so there's a lot of
factors involved but the Warriors
obviously has to win this game tonight
in order to get themselves a realistic
shot at being able to get that
three-peat when I'm not paying Pat Roddy
for that I know Harry Hall of Famer here
on the Rich Eisen show so the the
concept of the box and one being a janky
defense as as Steph Curry called it we
didn't see it too much in Game three I'm
wondering what your thought on that
subject that was much of the hoopla of
the coverage over the earlier part of
the week might be Rick well I mean you
do whatever you can try to do I mean you
try to put in some kind of a defense to
try to slow down a guy you try
everything possible in order to try to
find a way to get a victory if that's
the case other guys have to shoot the
ball well I mean the Warriors shot 33%
which is okay shooting threes that's 50%
from tubes but when the other team
shoots 47% that's pretty difficult to
make up that differential
I mean that's just an insane shooting
percentage so I have no problem with
that but the thing is is that you have
to have other people make them pay a
price for playing that kind of defense
and if you're not doing that then then
you don't stop doing what you're doing
so it's working what are your thoughts
on Kawhi Leonard's game work give me the
floor on him you know I've always liked
quiet you know because obviously you
know what San Antonio my son Brett who's
you know down there at the VP of
basketball operations out of TV and who
had two championships there always liked
the way he played here what I like about
kawaiii shows up when he puts that
uniform on you know you're gonna get
everything he's got he just goes about
his business he doesn't try to bring
attention to himself he just goes out
and plays and I love that I love that
about it Rick Barry hall-of-famer here
on the Rich Eisen show the topic du jour
one that I've got tons of callers that
want to talk about later on on the show
and when I lead with is the the incident
that happened with Kyle Lowry diving out
of bounds and getting a shove from a
partial owner of the Golden State
Warriors and Mark Stevens I don't know
if you know him personally or if you
knew him at all or know him at all I'm
wondering if you think this reaction by
the Warriors the fine and the banning
for a year from team activities is an
appropriate response Rick I would think
it's very inappropriate what he did and
and certainly whatever they justify as a
penalty for that I think it makes some
sense just like the players have no
business being in the stands doing
things agreeable with fans you know the
fans have no business doing anything
with the player and certainly not an
owner it was just you know one of those
things he lost control I'm sure whatever
he was I don't know what he was thinking
about but he just don't do anything like
that it was uncalled for
did did you ever have problems like that
when you were playing back in the day
well there's always there's always
things that happen before I mean I did
some stuff I probably got in huge
trouble and after the you know he had
that fiasco with the with the Pistons I
had one time jumped over the fence to go
so I'll be just the scary guy I never
did anything to him but the guy was
getting really personal about stuff you
know a fan could be rate you say all the
things about you personally when he
starts getting into talking about your
family and things of that nature I think
that person should be removed
the facility there's no call for that
whatsoever
part of the game is if you want to hack
a look you know you want to heckle a
player that's that's part of what Sports
is about you try to get into them you
try to affect this performance but not
when you get to the point of being
personal beyond him I mean it it's kind
of bad even to go ahead and get real
personal about the guy but I mean I
could I could live with that
so yeah I just think that's something
that has to be controlled without
question because then things get out of
hand
it's up to the officials and people to
control that just like in the game you
know as a player I keep telling people
the players will adjust to what the
officials are doing the only thing you
ask for them is to be consistent in the
way you call the game don't call it one
way in the first five minutes and a
different way in the last five minutes
Rick Perry Hall of Famer here on the
Rich Eisen show so what do you think
happens tonight do you think of W for
the Warriors happens tonight III really
honestly truly rich I don't know I mean
I really don't know I'm really concerned
I don't know but what's gonna happen if
clay let's get back to play how
effective is he going to be we know that
clay can go out there and just you know
do things that people have never done
before but he also sometimes struggles
with this shot so who knows I really
absolutely totally don't know that's the
beauty of sports you can analyze that
all you want you can look at the paper
you can look at all the things but you
still got to play the game you just have
to play the game and I know firsthand
come on I was you know the greatest
deficit in the history MBA finals 1975
we weren't supposed to be there we were
a joke it's gonna be one of the worst
mismatches ever and we swept a team that
was supposed to sweep us I know what can
happen and therefore I said let's just
see what happens as the game is played I
do know that the Warriors have got to
win this game to give themselves any
kind of a chance to be able to come away
with their third championship in a row
and I'm praying that they do come
through with a good win and and how
might a hamstring injury hamper clay
tonight as a shooter
I don't I don't know that's insane how
much is it I mean can you play is it
something that no aggravated again I
mean who knows I mean that's such a
touchy little thing I mean you just move
the wrong way it's weakened again I'm
certainly praying that it's not gonna
bother him and
to be able to play hard plus the fact on
defense having to move make those quick
movements when you're playing tough
defense and he's a really good defender
so how much of an impact is that going
to have we'll find out tonight I guess
so this is a tough situation for the
Warriors to be that's a great
opportunity I think for for the Toronto
Raptors to have a chance to win their
first ever championship by taking total
control of the series with the victory
tonight yeah well winner win or lose and
then as you just alluded to more of a
probability if there is a loss by the
Warriors tonight that this is the last
game for the Warriors in Oracle we're in
the arena now called Oracle that you go
way back in Rick what are your memories
of this arena well you know the two
fondest memories I have of that arena
because we didn't get to play the finals
there because they had a they had a they
had a nice show or something going on so
we couldn't play that we played at the
Cow Palace it would be Game seven
and you know even though I sung for most
of the game and played well at the end
and we beat Chicago in being seven to go
to the finals and also when that
happened our trainer dick the elite but
such a great guy had the presence of
mind
my son's scooter and John were both ball
boys and he had the presence of minds
and job is much younger to scoop John up
and run off the court with him to
protect them from getting trampled by
the fans so those are my mic two fondest
memories of there and the building so
it's going to be I hope it's not the
last one for them we'll see what happens
hey let me quickly tell your listeners
Gozer TLC all small letters TLC to
for.net TLC to for.net and they can get
themselves a two thousand dollar VIP
travel card no cost no obligation we'll
save the money cheaper than the online
services and a great opportunity to save
some money I go tells the resorts
worldwide TLC to for.net I was gonna ask
you if you had anything you wanted to
let my audience know but you you didn't
let me have the assist Rick you just
took it you just took the shot right
there well well you know I've done I've
done radio before no I know no you know
I was wrapping up I know you know I was
wrapping up
never do that just let me give the
assist out you were wide open you were
calling for the bar I know it's better
better better that than you threw me the
ball and I missed the shot okay that
that is true that is true thanks for the
call always appreciate it thanks the car
bye guys Rick 24 barrier for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app